私は
東京の原宿でワンピースと古着が中心の服屋をやっております
夜店を出してもすぐ4年目に入ります
今日もうちのワンピースを着ている人がいると
いうのを先ほど各家からモニターで見てましたありがとうございます
私は正直ここの場所でお話することに対してすごく迷いました
この業界の人としてすごい話っていうの私は何一つできないと思ったからです
なぜなら私は服やなんですけれども
服飾の学校でていません
販売員の経験もありません
もっと言うと中学校もまともに入ってません
天才とも努力家とも言えない私がこのような素晴らしい機会をいただいて本当にいいの
かと
最初はとっても不安に思いました
でもこの会場や画面の向こうに
以前の私のように
各駅や経験資格や特技が何もないと時々困ってしまっているってはもしかしたらいるか
もしれない
反対にそういうものはたくさんあるけど何から始めたらいいか
何が正解か分からないそういう人もいるかもしれない
そう思うと自然と私の場合についてお話ししてみたくなりました
そこで今日は
何も持っていない人が何かを見つける方法
何か持っている人がそれを生かせるようになる方法について私なりの考えをお伝えして
いきたいとおもいます
結論から申し上げますとそれは自分といえばこれを見つけることそしてそれを大切に
することです
私はただそれを実践していただけで今の仕事に巡り合いました
今日は私の過去を振り返りながら自分といえばこれを見つけること
そしてそれを大切にすることの良さについてお伝えできればと思います
まず私の自分といえばこれは大きく分けて2つあります
ひとつは自分の好きなファッションですもうひとつは自分の好きな働き方です
まず私の好きなファッションについてお話します
私の好きなファッションの軸は3つあります
それは服髪色です
もう見ての通り黙っていう感じだと思うんですけど説明します
私の好きな服はワンピースです特に古着のワンピースが大好きです
私の好きな髪型は前髪のあるボブカットです
もう何年もこの髪型です
そして好きな色は見ての通り赤色です
私は1年365日ほとんどの時間を赤色とボブとワンピースと共に過ごします
もう何年も好きなものがかわっていないこともあって私はこの印象っていうのが結構
周りにもあるみたいで
先日はこんな感じで私の真似をして私の仲間だ
みんな学科に触るほど私のイメージは毎日あ買った良い印象のようです
でも私はもちろん最初からこんな感じだったわけではありません
結構コロコロ変わってました
でも赤色とボブとワンピースはずっと好きでした
今みたいに毎日着たいなっていう感覚ではなくて
こちらのスライドでおわかりいただけるかなと思うんですけれどもこの数年間で結構
コロコロ変わってました
でもこの期間も赤色とボブとワンピースは大好きで
もちろん赤いワンピース着る日もたくさんいました
赤いるとボブとワンピース
そんなファッションに身を包む時はなんだか一番自信が持てて一番気分が良くて
だんだん自分と言えばこれだなぁって自分でも分かるようになってきて
これが自分のファッションこれが自分のスタイルと思ってすごく大事にするようになっ
てからはもっともっとどんどん好きになってきて今日も気分いいからこれ着ちゃおう
っていうのが毎日になってきてそうしてるうちにこれが象徴
これが特徴と言われるようになりました
次に私の好きな働き方についてお話しします
私は365日服やとして働いています
服屋として働いているというより冨久家として生きています私は仕事とプライベートの
境がほとんどありません
仕事も遊びも生活も全てが一緒くたで
すべて同じように楽しんでいます
楽しくて楽しくて仕方がないってことがしょっちゅうあります
そんなに好き勝手言いたくなるような人にはその方面の仕事か自然と引き寄せられて
くると私は思っています
そんなに好きじゃないなって人に何かをお願いするより
それが大好きってつにお任せしたほうがお互いにいいですよね
私の場合もそうで
そんなに好きな活かしていこうよというような感じで服やを作ろう
ブランドを作ろうというお声がけお話に発展していきました
私は特に複雑なことは何もしていません
自分の好きなものを好きなように好きなだけ迎え入れて言って
それを大切にしていって
それで自分といえばこれというものを見つけて言ってそれをもっともっと大切にして
いった結果今の服屋と言う前に楽しめる仕事に巡り合いました
でも仕事にはもちろん大変なこと空井こともたくさんあります
これだけ好きって言い張っている言い切っている私にも
そういうことはあります
私が今まで仕事をしてきて一番つらかったことそのことも今日お話ししたいと思います
私が生で仕事をしてきて一番つらかったこと
それは海外出張に行くときのことでした
古着を買い付けにアメリカに飛んだ時のことです
私は待ち受けていたのはこんな光景でした
皆さんこれがなんだかわかりますか
これは床に積まれた福井副でできた山です
これがこのツールを曲がってもスーッと奥までどこまでも先が見えないくらいつ続いて
いました
私はこれを初めて見たとき宝の山って言うようにいう人もいるんですけど
私にはとてもそんなふうには見えなくて
服なんてこれ以上作らなくていいって心から思ってしまいました
こんなに余っているのにどこに新しく作る必要があるんだろうって
服屋である自分が
なんだかやになるほど
ごっくん残念な気持ちになりました
大好きな服が大好きなワンピースがぐしゃぐしゃになって高く積まれている
誰かが一生懸命作ったはずの服が誰かの人生を彩ったはずの服がこんなことになってっ
私はもう服なんてもいらないなーって思ってしまいました
この中には
寄付で集められたものもあるということなので一概に全部を悪いとよくないとまとめて
しまうことはできないかもしれません
でも明らかに服が有り余っている作られすぎている
だからこそこういう光景が生まれてしまうのではないかと私はそう感じています
今私が着ているこの赤いワンピースは
この服の山から見つけたものです
私はこれを着ているとあの時のことを鮮明に思い出す
すごく熱い気持ちになります
私はこんな素敵な服が1枚でも多く息を吹き返すならん
そういう服を乱す届けることができるならそういう服屋で荒れるなろう
服屋を続けたいもっとこの仕事を突き詰めてみたいと思いました
でも大切にされる服って何だろうと私は考えました
そこで日本に帰国してから私はたくさんの人にこんな質問をしてみました
大切にしている服ってありますか
捨てられない服ってどんなものですか
何十人が
100人以上の人ですかね本当にたくさんの人につきました
あんな起伏が捨てられているし私の会社も結構大きな会社でたくさん服を作っているの
で
何服について考えてる人っていないだろうなぁくらいの気持ちで聞いてしまったんです
けど私が質問した人はみんな愛おしそうに一つ一つ丁寧に答えてくれました
お金を貯めて買った服パレスからのプレゼント
おばあちゃんからのお下がり作られている背景に共感して買っているよって裕福
私はたくさんのストーリーに出会うことができました
そしてその結果ストーリーを語れる服は大切にされる副都
そういうシンプルな結果にたどり着きました
ストーリーの方れる服は大切に着られる服になり
簡単に捨てられない服になります
そういう服になれる服
それを届けること
それを日々追求することが
私にとっての
自分といえばこれ
自分の好きな働き方です
ストーリーのある服大切にされる副私にはどんなことができるだろう
私たちにはどんなことができるかなーとスタッフに相談してみたり自分で考え抜いて
私たちは微力ですがこんなことをしてます
お店で
商品について説明することはもちろん私はオリジナルの服に名前を付けて物語を発信し
ています
例えばこれは私たちのワンピースという名前の服です
あとは奴に見せたいワンピースとかイタリアを走るサロペットとかそういう名前の服が
あります
これは決してふざけて付けているわけではなくて
実話を元にして実はから名前を付けています
私たちは古着屋なので
沢山の古着に出会いますがそれらを丁寧にメンテナンスしてなるべく良い状態にして人
に届けること
それから特別のヴィンテージに出会ったときにはそれを方にとってオリジナルを新しく
作ることそういうことでストーリーを紡いでいくということにも挑戦しています
こういうことをすることによってストーリーを感じてもらって手に取ってもらえる服
そういうものは大事にされやすいです
実際にお客様の中にも私たちにお手紙をくれる人
メッセージをくれる人たくさんいます
そういう方々は皆
ストーリーのある服をまとい捨てられない服だという風に言ってくれています
自分といえばこれを
追求し続け
それは
自分を象徴するものになります
赤色とボブとワンピース私はこんなにわかりやすいものが自分の象徴になっていますが
皆さん一人一人にもこういうものはあると思います
自分といえばこれがあなたといえばそれというもの
認識に変わって行くと
自分の自信に変わってそれが仕事につながる可能性もどんどん広がります
私はこういうことにこそワクワクします
周りの意見はいったん聞かなきゃ大丈夫です
周りの色々言ってくることは言っちゃ無視して大丈夫ので自分は何が好きか何に興味が
あるのかどんなものが好きなのか
向き合ってみてください
自分の声は自分にしか聞こえません
自分の好きなものに自分が気づいてあげてください
それを迎え入れて大切にして自分といえばこれというものに育て上げることこそ私のお
伝えしたいことです
皆さんには自分といえばこれというものは何かありますか
今日の帰り道少し考えてみてください
自分といえばこれというものを大切にして自分にしかできない自分の象徴を見つけてみ
てください
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]